WITH.
SHE WILL GET IT DONE.
>> Sandra:
>> Tucker: WELL, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN AWARDING
MANY MILLIONS IN CORONAVIRUS
STIMULUS MONEY TO PEOPLE BASED
ON THEIR SKIN COLOR ALONE.
THIS SILL LEGAL, IMMORALE AND GO
UNCHALLENGED.
STEPHEN MILLER IS HERE.
HIS GROUP JUST WON AN INJUNCTION
AGAINST THIS RACIST POLICY.
HE JOINS US.
THANKS FOR DOING THIS.
EXPLAIN WHAT THIS MONIES TO THE
NONLAWYERS, IF YOU WOULD.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
YOU KNOW, I'M NOT A LAWYER
EITHER.
I'M A PERSON THAT CARES DEEPLY
ABOUT INJUSTICE AND WHAT IS
HAPPENING TO OUR COUNTRY LIKE
MILLIONS OF YOUR LISTENERS.
I PUT TOGETHER A GROUP, HIRED
THE BEST LAWYERS IN THE COUNTRY
THE STAND UP FOR CIVIL RIGHTS IN
AMERICA.
WE HEAR TWO TERM AS LOT,
SYSTEMIC RACISM AND
INSTITUTIONAL RACISM.
IN THIS CASE, WE HAVE REAL LIFE
SYSTEMIC RACISM AND
INSTITUTIONAL RACISM WHERE
FARMERS AND RESTAURANT OWNERS
ARE BEING DENIED BECAUSE OF
THEIR SKIN COLOR.
IT'S BIGOTST AND
UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
I'M GLAD THAT WE WON FOR OUR
CLIENTS IN THE RESTAURANT CASE
AN INJUNCTION.
SO THEY CAN APPLY.
NOW WE'RE SEEKING FOR ALL OTHERS
IN THE SAME SITUATION.
THE SAME RIGHT UNDER LAW TO
APPLY JUST AS ANY OTHER
AMERICAN.
WE WANT EQUALITY, NOT EQUITY,
WHICH IS CODE WORD FOR RACISM.
>> Tucker: WHY ISN'T THE NAACP
JOINING YOU?
I THOUGHT THEY WERE AGAINST
DISCRIMINATION?
>> WHAT WE'RE FINDING OUT, WHICH
IS TRAGIC AND HEART BREAKING, IS
THAT PROGRESSIVES IN THIS
COUNTRY ARE WILLING TO USE THE
AWESOME POWER OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO PUP  -- PUNISH
PEOPLE BECAUSE OF THE WAY THEY
LOOK OR THEIR ANCESTORS CAME
FROM.
IF WE ALLOW THAT TO HAPPEN TO
NEIGHBORS, FELLOW CITIZENS,
CHILDREN, THE AMERICAN
EXPERIMENT IS OVER.
THOSE ARE THE STAKES HERE.
THAT IS WHY I'M DOING THIS.
THAT'S WHY I AM SUING THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION TO SAY IN THIS
COUNTRY YOU DO NOT PUNISH PEOPLE
BECAUSE THEY LOOK A CERTAIN WAY,
BECAUSE THEIR ANCESTORS COME
FROM A CERTAIN PLACE.
THE GOVERNMENT HAS A POWER TO
DESTROY A BITS BECAUSE OF THE
WAY SOMEONE LOOKS?
WHAT IS NEXT?
PUT SOMEONE IN JAIL BECAUSE THE
WAY THEY LOOK?
TAKE AWARE THEIR LIFE AND
DREAMS?
THIS IS TO PREY.
IT'S SICK WHAT IS GOING ON AND
ABSOLUTELY A VIOLATION OF LAW.
>> Sandra:
>> Tucker: YEAH.
IT'S ILLEGAL AND EVERYTHING
ELSE.